هنا وبين محاصيل الخشخاش رافق برنامج
للقصه بقيه قوات مكافحه المخدرات التابعه
للطالبان في حملاتها لاتلاف الافيون في
البلد الذي ينتج ما يعادل 80% من الانتاج
العالمي غير المشروع للافيون وفق مكتب
الامم المتحده للمخدرات والجريمه رغم
الحظر الذي فرضته طالبان على زراعه وتجاره
الافيون منذ ابريل 2022
للقصه بقيه تقسم مراكز زراعه الافيون
وشبكات تهريبه ومعامل صناعه المخدرات التي
تبقي تجارتها قائمه في افغانستان من
افغانستان حيث يتم تحميل المخدرات قد
تستلم الشحنه 50 يدا الى ان تصل الى
مالكها الرئيسي لدينا موظفون في كل منطقه
فمثلا لديه انا في بلوشستان
وانا انظم كل شيء
كالمسلحين والمرشدين هل تعتقد ان من يهرب
طنا من المخدرات سيفعل ذلك بالاهتمام ودون
اي تفكير ايا كان من يهربها فهو يعرض
حياته للخطر
هو يوظف مضحين مسلحين الى تضيع ثلاثه او
اربعه ملايين دولار هباء
تصنع هذه المخدرات بادوات بدائيه داخل
معامل سريه تقليديه في المناطق النائيه
استطاع برنامج للقصه بقيه رصد نشاط احد
معامل صناعه الهيروين جنوبيه افغانستان
حيث يتطلب انتاج كيلوغرام واحد من
الهيروين حوالي 29 كلغ من مستخلص الافيون
مع مركبات كيميائيه لانتاج المورفين
لتتحول بعد بضع ساعات الى الهيروين زياده
القيود على مستخلصات الافيون تعني
ارتفاعها مش ارباحنا هنا نشتري الكيلو
جرام الواحد من الهيروين ب 2600 او 2800
دولار نشن عمليات تستهدف مصانع المخدرات
في افغانستان اعتقلنا 7000 مشتبه بتهريب
المخدرات دمرنا 600 مصنع لانتاج المخدرات
ودمرنا 11 الف هكتار من حقول الخشخاش كما
عالجنا 90000 من مدم نين المخدرات هذا
العام
بوتيره بطيئه تحل حقول القمح الذهبيه محل
محاصيل الخشخاش رغم ضعف مردودها الربحي
للمزارعين الا ان منظمه الفاو تعد بدعم
حوالي مليونين ومائه الف افغاني بمشاريع
انتاج القمح التي يرعاها البنك الدولي مع
نهايه نوفمبر 2023